we start tonight with the Fox News Alert
today massive and great news the Dow
Jones Industrial Average jumped a
whopping 1290 points and as the Dow the
S&P and as the Nasdaq all saw record
high highest single day point gains in
American history now after a week of
Corona related panic lies propaganda
misinformation thankfully the market is
roaring back and in a big way we have a
full report coming up on the program
tonight but first in 246 days and it's
gonna go like that you are the ultimate
jury you will have a chance to once
again shock the world and send President
Trump back to the White House for four
more years but it needs to be very clear
to every American and we will try and
make it clear every night on this
program and the Democrats the media mob
they will stop at nothing they will do
anything and I mean anything to stop
Donald Trump their rage hate Trump
psychosis is even far worse than I
thought the level of derangement is off
the charts and now tonight especially I
want you to pay very close attention as
we prove our point because they're now
using the natural fear of a virus as a
political weapon and we have all the
evidence to prove it a shameful
politicizing weaponizing of yes the
corona virus remember first Russia
Russia Russia and Peach and Peach and
Peach obstruction obstruction whatever
now the left the Democrats the media mob
they are smearing the president and his
administration over the spread of the
corona virus in beyond egregious ways
the double standard in hypocrisy of the
mob and the Democrats has never been
worse so tonight we ask you pay very
close attention as we prove this point
to you now the information we are giving
you is not information you were going to
find anywhere else and it will expose
yet again the absolute corruption
dishonesty fraud and the political
agenda of Democrats and the media mob
well their state-run TV we start with
smear number one for days the left has
been claiming the president is not
prepared to handle the disease
effectively well as a matter of fact
Biden
burg the entire mob in the media others
said president Trump cut the funding to
NIH and CDC that is a hundred percent
false the exact opposite happened
funding actually went up in fact a
recent study from John Hopkins
University ranked the United States
number one for number one in the world
at pandemic preparedness and we are by
far the most prepared the net next live
from the media mob and Democrats is the
claim the president did not act quickly
enough that is a bold-faced lie
let's look at the truth that nobody else
will report and we have an actual
timeline and you can follow along at
home it's like follow the bouncing ball
now this officially started believe it
or not on December 30th 2019 not that
long ago we had a cluster of patients
with pneumonia in this unknown province
that that was observed in muha China now
that was reported to the World Health
Organization
it wasn't until January 7th that the
virus the corona virus was actually
identified and isolated in these
patients than just three weeks later on
January 31st of this year the president
declared a public health emergency
that meant Americans returning from
areas most impacted they were subject to
mandatory quarantine two weeks on
military bases that's when the travel
ban began two days later temporary
travel ban went into effect for all non
US citizens who recently visited China
and my sources who were actually in the
room when the president made this
decision on January 31st said well
they're about 25 people in the room no
one agreed with the president to
implement the travel ban said that
there'd be political consequences if he
did but he did it anyway and he did it
in record time everyone else said now
maybe it's too early he made the call
and my sources confirmed to me tonight
you can stop right there this one early
bold decision of this president likely
prevented thousands and thousands of
Americans from contracting this virus as
anyone in the media mob told you that
and meanwhile it wasn't until February
the 11th that the World Health
Organization officially named the virus
President was way ahead of them now a
task force led by Trump's number-two
vice president Pence is underway it is
filled with America's
top scientists so far thankfully less
than 10 people in the country have died
from this virus now we need to put that
in perspective let us compare this to
h1n1 swine flu virus as it's known now
this at the u.s. in April of 2009
it wasn't until six months later in
October of 2009 after more than 20,000
Americans were hospitalized more than a
thousand of our fellow citizens died
only then did President Obama and yeah
quid pro quo Joe declare a national
emergency
after 20,000 of our fellow citizens
hospitalized more than a thousand dead
Americans now do you remember at that
time anybody in the media stirring up
the type of hysteria as they're doing
now do you remember the end of days
predictions did the stock market tanked
because of all the reckless lying and
fear-mongering that did not happen in
2009 in fact the market went up as swine
flu cases mounted pretty interesting a
tale of two presidents on the one side
you got Obama Biden they get the White
Glove treatment from of course the
willing accomplices and fellow radical
extreme socialists in the Democratic
Party on the other side the mob in three
weeks bludgeons president's rump
weaponizing this virus to destroy him
politically one person at Yahoo News
even suggesting this could be Trump's
Katrina the Washington Post also openly
wondering if it would become Trump's
Katrina New York Times hack Paul Krugman
actually cheered how do you cheer when
we're losing money when the stock market
fell 25,000 New York Times editorial New
York Times said this is the Trump virus
writing if you're feeling awful you know
who to blame by the way as president
Trump was literally reacting in record
time what were the Democrats doing to
prepare this country for the pandemic at
the end of January and early February
well they couldn't be bothered why
because they were all consumed with
their impeachment conspiracy theories
hoax and witch-hunt now the final vote
didn't take place on a pitchman until
February the 12th nearly two weeks after
president Trump acted decisively with an
aggressive plan frankly unprecedented to
stop the spread of the corona virus when
he had his travel ban put in place he
did all of this while he was being
impeached and when the president put in
place the travel ban at that time that
guy
quid pro quo Joe called the president's
travel ban and quarantine efforts quote
part of a record of xenophobia and
fear-mongering oh so many more thousands
of people how many more would have
contracted the virus we didn't
quarantine people that came in from
China are citizens for two weeks and we
didn't have a travel ban sorry your part
of the world sick you can't get in he
did that in three weeks
Biden Obama they waited six months and a
thousand people died in 29 2009 and 10
fake news CNN what were they saying at
the time with the travel ban well they
were promoting the potential stigma and
fear that the travel ban would cause and
fake news CNN would have also been
responsible if in fact the ban wasn't in
place and thousands and thousands of our
fellow Americans contracted this disease
and they'd be critical of Trump for
doing that and now the Democrats and the
mob they are just outright lying
you got NBC News fake news CNN MSDN see
others share Hollywood actually claiming
that the president is calling the
coronavirus a hoax no that's another
complete lie instead the president
called the weaponization and
politicizing of the virus a hoax and we
have the tape to prove it take a look
now the Democrats are politicizing the
corona virus you know that
they are politicizing it we did one of
the great jobs you say House President
Trump doing they go home not good not
good one of my people came up to me and
said mr. president they tried to beat
you on Russia Russia Russia that didn't
work out too well they couldn't do it
they tried the impeachment hoax they
tried it over and over they've been
doing it since you got in it's all
turning they lost it's all turning think
of it think of it and this is that new
hoax president didn't call the virus a
hoax no we put in place quarantined and
he put in place a travel ban but the mob
and the media why would they ever let
facts get in the way of a good anti
Trump smear which is all they've been
doing for three years take a look just
tonight at a rally he went a step
further and called the coronavirus a
hoax this is the same president who
referred to the corona virus as a hoax
how did they answer that a guy like
senator Sanders is more capable than
Donald Trump who is called a coronal
violence by the way a hoax
president Trump laid it to Democrats for
raising alarm calling it a hoax you know
the idea that Donald Trump said just
several days ago this was a democratic
coach what in God's name is he talking
about
I find it incomprehensible that the
president would do something as inane as
calling it a hoax which he did last
night in South Carolina he said that the
Democrats making so much of it is a
democratic hoax not that the virus was a
home listen they're all lying yet again
because of a political agenda I hate
Trump agenda but not a word not a peep
in 2009 and ten twenty thousand of our
fellow Americans contracting swine flu
six months what a fight an Obama
do-nothing a thousand dead Americans all
now will declare a national emergency
that is how corrupt and morally bankrupt
your media mob has become and your
Democratic Party is and you got
late-night liberal Bill Maher well he
might take the cake over the weekend he
actually claimed that the president
would like to use the virus to declare
martial law this is the same guy by the
way
that wanted Oh a recession because it
would help the Democrats take a look now
since Trump I think is not gonna leave
anyway
might as well run Bernie he's not he's
not and by the way when the virus gets
mad he's gonna declare martial law what
lies conspiracy theories smear slander
besmirch them from the media unlike
anything we've ever experienced this is
a raw naked political agenda they hate
the president but they also hate those
of us smelly Walmart Trump supporters I
believe in God our guns our Bibles you
know Constitution they're not looking
out for your safety or security or
well-being the one thing they care about
and the only thing is placating this
psychotic rage hypocrisy and double
standard because they hate Donald Trump
that's why this election means something
more than any other in my lifetime 246
days you cannot reward this